was glauben sie wie geht die feuerwehr
vor ort jetzt vor
das ist würde ich als laie jetzt sagen
das schlimmste was man sich vorstellen
kann wenn solch einen wolkenkratzer in
flammen steht uns vor allem so massiv
bereits in flammen steht gibt es da
pläne gibt es da szenarien wie eine
feuerwehr dann davor geht ja die genaue
einsatztaktik die feuerwehr in südkorea
gibt das kann ich ihnen nicht
beantworten
die oberste priorität und dass es
weltweit gleich hat die rettung von
menschen aus lebensgefahr und jetzt ist
es sozusagen wird der fokus der
einsatzkräfte seien alle menschen die
dort in ihrem gebäude sich befinden
leben unmöglich unverletzt aus diesem
gebäude zu retten wenn ich das richtig
gelesen habe müssen das so 33 35
stockwerke hoch etwa sein dieses gebäude
das heißt also auch eine klassische
drehleiter die reichen bis zum zehnten
obergeschoss der grossratswahlen haben
dazu noch rettungsfahrzeuge teleskopmast
fahrzeuge die reichen dann so in etwa 40
50 meter hoch so was wird da auch geben
wo das reicht natürlich nicht bis oben
das heißt es beim bau dieses gebäudes
einen zweiten baulichen rettungsweg
gegeben haben der unabhängig vom ersten
sein muss hier werden dann sicherlich
die einsatzkräfte nach oben zu arbeiten
um dort die menschen zu retten und
wieder auch die brandbekämpfung
konzentrieren bis zum zehnten stock
haben sie gesagt die drehleiter bei
einer sozusagen normalen feuerwehr bis
zu welchem stockwerk ihrer einschätzung
nach gibt denn bei einer großstadt
vorher wie wer wie dort in der stadt zu
vorhandenen bis zu welchem stockwerk
gibt die leiter da
also so dass die die höchsten
drehleitern die produziert werden also
55 maximal so wenn man davon ausgeht
dass das einen ein stockwerk etwa drei
meter in der höhe bemisst können sich
leicht ausrechnen dass das so etwa bis
zum 20 obergeschoss etwa käthe eine eine
reichweite einer wirklich auch großen
drehleiter das heißt also man die ganz
obersten stockwerke wird man mit einem
einem fahrzeug was eine drehleiter
aufgebaut hat nicht herankommen
hier muss es also bauliche lösungen
geben und die werden mit sicherheit auch
in diesem gebäude vorhanden seien
bauliche maßnahmen haben sie
angesprochen also ist das dann die man
sich das vorstellt wie man das auch hier
aus deutschland kennt spezielle
treppenhäuser die dann brand geschützt
sind ja die die müssen so konstruiert
werden dass wir zumindest auch baulich
voneinander getrennten das heißt ich
habe gehe ich aber davon aus dass auf
der linken seite einen bettenhausen auf
der rechten seite und diese nicht
miteinander verbunden weshalb wenn ein
treppenraum ausfällt weil es dort zu
einem ereignis gekommen ist und
brandrauch einbringt dann muss der
zweite treppenraum frei sein um die
menschen zu retten und b um das vorgehen
der feuerwehr zu gewährleisten
neben solchen häusern ist dass er das
zeitungen verbaut sind das heißt hier
gibt es die möglichkeit die müssen dann
eben mit einem schlauch bis nach oben
ins 33 ziehen sondern man nimmt dann das
material mit und entweder gibt es hier
spezielle feuerwehr aufzüge mit denen
man fahren kann die besonders auch für
den feuerwehreinsatz aufgerüstet sind
oder was jeden dann tatsächlich den
treppenraum nehmen und muss dann
wirklich bis zum 30 33 stockwerk des
vorarbeiten um dort dann die
brandbekämpfung durchzuführen das heisst
also jetzt eben auch eine eine
körperliche eine typische
so starke belastbarkeit ein
feuerwehrmann mit einer vorher für
frauen gefordert
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren